colombia is marking one month
since a wave of deadly protests began
they started as an
outcry against a controversial tax
reform but
soon turned into a national uprising
against
growing poverty and inequality weeks of
negotiations to end the unrest have
failed to bear fruit
and the prospect of a peaceful solution
seemed to slip even further on friday
when president ivan duque announced he
was deploying the military
after more people died in demonstrations
plumes of smoke tower above the city of
papojan
like monuments to the resistance
[Music]
a month of protest has turned streets
across the country into smoldering
battle scars from what they see as their
fight for justice
the message we want to deliver is that
we are tired of so much injustice from
this corrupt government
of so much inequality we're not asking
for any handouts
we're not asking them to give us
anything we're only asking for an
opportunity to grow
for equality not only for the rich
but also for the poor
[Applause]
the protests erupted when president ivan
duque sought to raise taxes to pay for
the pandemic
the blowback forced him to kill the bill
but the outcry continued
an outrage over the government's
handling of a crisis that seen
unemployment double
an inequality surge
attempts to program into the standoff
have so far proved futile
according to official figures more than
45 people have been killed
dozens more disappeared and thousands on
both sides were injured
but human rights groups say the real toe
is likely much higher
and it's only likely to get worse in the
days ahead
on friday president duke said he's
deploying the army to the epicenter of
the unrest
kali where at least three people were
killed in the last 24 hours
let me be absolutely clear
as of tonight we begin the maximum
deployment of military assistance
in the city of galilee and the
department of ebay
islands of anarchy do not have a place
in our country
meeting with colombia's vice president
on friday u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken expressed his concern
over the deepening crisis in the country
backing the people's right
to protest peacefully
for now though the deathly cat and mouse
game on the streets of columbia
continues
you